- [Narrator] Rates of RSV or
Respiratory Syncytial Virus,
have been surging since August.
That's weeks earlier
than the typical season.
- Pediatric hospitals are
pretty stretched right now.
- [Narrator] So doctors
are warning of a possible-
- Triple-demic.
That means cases of Covid, flu, and RSV,
a virus that's been impacting children,
are all expected to rise.
- [Narrator] Here's what
to know about the surge
in RSV and what it means for your winter.
RSV is a virus spread through droplets
from coughing and
sneezing, and on surfaces.
It's so common, that nearly all children
come in contact with the
virus by the age of two.
And while RSV feels like
a cold for most people,
it can be severe for some
infants and older adults.
According to the CDC,
about 58,000 children
under five are hospitalized
due to RSV every year.
In pre-Covid times,
hospitalizations looked like this,
peaking in January.
But in the first year of the
pandemic, RSV rates flattened.
That's because Covid safety measures,
like distancing and face masks,
also likely protected
people from other diseases.
But around the summer of
2021, cases of RSV shot up.
- [Brianna] Once you sort
of start mingling again
and dropping those restrictions,
you get a lot of cases happening at once.
- [Narrator] There's no
approved vaccine for RSV,
and children who didn't
get sick from the virus
in 2020 or 2021, might have
less immunity protection.
And for this fall surge-
- [Brianna] There's a
couple things at play here.
One of them sort of
being that a lot of kids
have gone back to school in the fall,
and this year there was
significantly less masking
in a lot of schools and
other safety precautions
that there were for the past two years.
There's been less exposure.
Some of, like, the tiniest kids
haven't seen RSV before, and
so you have sort of a higher
susceptible population
among sort of the youngest.
- [Narrator] This surge
in RSV comes at a time
when other respiratory illnesses,
like the Rhinovirus and Enteroviruses
have increased
hospitalizations in children.
So doctors are bracing for more cases.
- The Connecticut Children's
Medical Center in Hartford
is considering setting up a field hospital
in case things get worse.
- [Narrator] And some
physicians are worried
about precautionary measures
for high risk infants.
- Vulnerable babies, as a precaution,
get injections of this monoclonal antibody
during the normal respiratory season.
But if, you know, RSV strikes
earlier or during the summer,
like, a lot of those
babies, unless hospitals
sort of can anticipate
and keep up quickly,
sort of lose that extra protection.
- [Narrator] It's not just RSV.
The flu season arrived earlier
than usual this year, too.
- [Brianna] There is a lack of exposure,
because less people have had
it for the past two seasons,
lower vaccination rates,
because, you know,
that's sort of a better
way to build up exposure.
Less precautions as people are heading
inside and into schools
and workplaces again.
- [Narrator] And that,
combined with a possible uptick
in Covid cases, has doctors
worried about a triple threat
of RSV, Covid and flu.
- A confluence of all of these
viruses could put hospitals
under serious strain this winter,
because over the last two winters,
hospitals were completely slammed
entirely just with Covid.
And what we saw during the pandemic,
is that if a hospital is overrun,
it's harder to get in for
any other sort of care
that you might need.
An overwhelmed hospital
isn't good for anybody.
- [Narrator] To help
reduce hospital capacity,
health officials are encouraging people
to get their flu and Covid vaccines.